i read this somewhere yeah that you went
up to prince
when he was alive obviously and you
didn't go to the funeral but when you
went
you went up to prince and you said he
was in some club or something
no he had his own after party after he
performed on snl
right there's hour after party then he
had his i would be thrilled to work on
saturday night live but i would not want
to go to any [ __ ] party
i'd be exhausted so princess parties it
should be noted he would then
do a concert right um he's done that
after his
own shows but this one they had a dj and
they were serving
that a little buffet of macaroni and
cheese oh my god
wow he really knew how to party i want
mac and cheese it was
it was it was pretty like quiet and
there was like a dj ant so but that's
the one i wanted to go to
it went to that yeah and then i'm such a
prince fan
and i really wanted to tell him this
and i wanted him you know in my ego to
say something back
nice sure you know um so because he had
just performed on the show
so i walked up to he was sitting alone
eating macaroni and cheese and i was
like
this is true this is true yeah and i was
so i sort of carefully sat down i was
like hey i just wanted to tell you i
think you are the greatest
and he said you know what i think the
greatest is and i was like what
he said this macaroni
[Laughter]
and then i had to walk away from the
table
alone back backwards because you know
it's almost a joke or not a joke i
couldn't tell
why wha wait a second why do you think
he does like did he do that because
he just wanted to humiliate you or or is
he trying to be funny what the [ __ ] is
going on i think somewhere in between
just as a you know just to be an
optimist i thought maybe he's just
trying to be funny or
because it wasn't it didn't feel mean
it's just
like the cool kid in school who gets to
pick on somebody and you know what i
mean like you know you were being very
sincere and i think you're the greatest
and
it's not easy to do that ultimately like
prince the resp like prince's
responsibility was to always be prince
yeah but in the moment fred was like
walking
backward from the table yeah i'm about
to go on
yeah that the year that you guys were
going to talk to him about doing prince
show and they kept telling you who would
talk to you after
rehearsal yes and then instead i talked
to his assistant what's that story
well my memory of it and tell me if i'm
wrong is you and maya
we're going to talk to him and ask him
to be in prince because maya played
beyonce
and i i always my favorite one that you
did was the prince show where your
prince and
and maya goes oh princess i've never
seen him laugh this hard
and you barely you just twirled your lip
a little bit
and the assistant he was rehearsing on
thursday prince was rehearsing yeah and
they said as soon as he's done he's
going to come and talk to you guys
yes and then the minute he finished
disappeared he just walked
all the way down the hall right into the
elevator yeah what is that like why
would they say
prince is going to talk to you and then
have him disappear like why
what is this i guess that's what he does
it disappears you know i think it was
easy to be prince i think it was
probably really hard to be prince's
assistant yes
yeah yeah just in the morning where it's
like we gotta nail down your schedule
you know what i realize about the three
of you you're good friends i feel like
fred and bill bonded because they both
walked off saturday night live together
and i feel that was bonding right am i
and
it was very bonding it was very bonding
actually yeah did you two sit down
together and say we're both gonna leave
basically yeah yeah even even how we
were gonna do it
yeah and then the whole season was us
kind of doing
you know last christmas show we would
look at each other late
this is it that's last one and then and
then last and then that last week it was
just table read like people read last
night were you both neurotic about it
together i mean did you go
oh [ __ ] what are we going to do
afterwards it could not work out maybe
and
you just kind of that was it it was just
kind of we just wanted to enjoy it too
we wanted to
really appreciate every moment we had a
kind of fun thing whereas at the good
nights we had this thing of like okay
we're up at good nights we're waving at
the end of the show
and we said when we step off the stage
we're officially
ex-snl cast members there's almost an
excited three we went one
yeah we looked at the floor we looked at
the floor and we stepped off at the same
time we're like an hour
that's what you guys are doing during
that end of the show i think you guys
are all having fun talking about so
you're talking about stepping off in
unison yeah
here we go let's go and then freeze
frame credits came up that's the end of
our story
i still think that's such a great
tradition on saturday night live that
ending of the show where the host says
good night and everybody i don't know
why that's so fascinating i think i
could stand 20 minutes of that like
just watching the dynamics i love
watching that because you see the real
people you see what they're like
how they stand yes it's more fun to
watch than to
be there though don't you think why is
it awkward sometimes well you're aware
that it's being watched right yeah not
quite apart everybody is watching you
celebrate
and sometimes you do that thing where
you see somebody who had a great thing
in the show and you say
great show and then you turn and there's
another person you say great show and
then you turn and there's a person whose
thing got cut
yeah right and they're miserable
remember ones that were like a lot of
times people cheer and then sometimes it
was a good show we'll get a standing
ovations great but the worst is when
they
good night everybody and immediately
people start leaving
and you're like do you know when you do
a bad show do you can you tell that the
audience will be getting up and leaving
or is that the
the indication for you the first
indication no you know during the course
if it's bad
you do yeah those are actually kind of
fun where we will sit down and make up
chair and be like
yeah i mean you'd rather i mean in
all things being equal you'd rather have
an f than a c minus yeah because those
are the ones you remember
i don't understand that you may rather
have a grade of an f
than a c you'd rather have a really
horrible show than it's sort of a
mediocre one
very in the same way that i think fred
was lucky the prince said mac and cheese
we remember the terrible ones
right as a thing that we all went
through that we can laugh about now
they're not really fun to go through at
the time
right does lorne lecture people
afterwards no no you don't get any of
that when it's
really bad that's when lauren will tell
you it wasn't terrible
yeah and he'll say you know i think the
crowd tonight
you know i think you know it's that and
they'll always be there
you know what tells you when you have a
bad show is new york city will tell you
the next day i'll be going to a bodega
with my kid and be like
hey that thing you did last night the
firemen that was dumb
really yeah all right thank you